hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to a very special episode of fandango
indie movie Guide coming to you from the
2017 the Sundance Film Festival each day
here at the festival I've been taking
this camera out and about so I thought I
would do a compilation of my video
diaries
welcome to snowy Park City I wrote down
some facts and figures about this year's
Sundance because I've known like that
they heard 13,000
180-acre feature
one thousand nine
878 Turtles raining and 16
all around pop city and also at Salt
Lake City what gives you satisfaction at
the end of the festival I think probably
the thing that excites me the most is to
see the initial idea of trying to create
something that would give an opportunity
to yours to tell their stories in a way
and also have a place to grow that we've
created them it's two hours before the
press screening of an inconvenient
sequel that's the documentary follow-up
to Al Gore's An Inconvenient Truth that
came out quite a few years ago again
about current climate change and I'm
gonna go in and line up that was the
amazing al gore speaking he rightfully
so got a standing ovation and it was
really inspiring documentary very
powerful surprisingly emotional and
something that just feels really needed
right now
now we're lining up for I have to look
at the title to so long I don't feel at
home in the
record by making flash he was an actor
in murder party and guru inand green
room all of Jeremy's sannyas films this
is his directorial debut starring
melanie lynskey and elijah wood running
out of breath cos they'll shoot the
characters were very quirky there's some
really good humor in there and you could
tell that he was he's been influenced or
inspired or very similar to Jeremy Soule
in the egg with the violence and a lot
of shifts between tone with humor and
drama of tension but most the time they
worked so I think I really enjoyed it so
there you have it that was day one I
hope you guys enjoyed watching this and
tomorrow I'll be back with much more
[Music]
good morning it is Sundance day 2 it is
snowing again
[Music]
so that was director Maggie Betts
novitiates
took us a while to figure out exactly
how to say that this does Margaret quali
who is actually handing dales daughter
and she was also in that cool Kenzo
perfume ad which was just pulling you
know directed by Spike Jonze I just a
bad impression then but that was really
cool she plays a girl who is deciding to
become a nun in the 90s teen all-female
class there was only one or two guys
it's working it's a necklace that was
nice to see so many female characters
and it does deal with that idea of faith
doing my snow face which is like no
that's really attractive Alicia I
apologize just saw LA Times directed and
written and starring Michelle Morgan
what a talented lady it's very
insightful in particular two people
living in LA all about love in LA
hilarious and dark I loved it I hope
that was informative and mercy to me
good morning
it is the Nance day three I think we
have pink hats Dean Fandango and we are
off to the women's March but it is
snowing so ha
foldings people actually makes mana try
[Applause]
we have a ton of a class named
intermediary so help you stay grounded
QA and the standing ovation firm mud
bound a superbly directed film by Dee
Reese Hawk its brutal brutal look at
race relations during world war two in
the south and it's heartbreaking but
fantastic cast so much fun being here at
the Sundance Film Festival I hope that
you guys enjoy coming with me and I'll
see you tomorrow
[Music]
it is Sundance day four and this is
badly needed things really a miserable
experience in every way but now there's
the other stories one time I want to see
what we through it and that's the only
way to do it oh it's freezing cold but
that was Taylor Sheridan director of
Wind River and he says this is his third
in his thematic trilogy the new American
frontier trilogy just held together by a
theme Sicario hella high water and now
Wind River I would say it feels more
scenario than hella high water but I've
seen a lot of hella high water
comparisons online great score by Nick
Cave fantastic work by Jeremy Renner and
Elizabeth Olsen
if you'd like to go through those movies
then you'll really love this one too I
was on the edge of my seat through most
of it and also it's very cold on screen
lots of snow and I was cold in the
theater and now I'm cold again so it's
very cold exciting thriller
love some is I actually glass as some
event anthem sitting next and so overall
the movies that are buzzing it seem to
be overwhelmingly mud bound and the big
sick although just tonight we're hearing
about call me by your name so I'll see
if I can get to that in the morning it
is at 8:30 which means I'll probably
only have like three or four hours sleep
so I'll set my alarm and see how I feel
in the morning and I will see you for
day 5 good morning everyone it is
Sundance day 5 and look at this snow the
city is white Main Street you can't even
see it a huge snowstorm overnight it's
making it difficult to get around and
you know you should be proud of me
because this morning I actually chose
sleep over a movie
[Music]
it's great to be here just so pretty bad
and that's produced by the Miami Island
guys surprisingly sweet very funny
about a boy he's abducted and then he
gets found when he's older and he loves
his television show cruisers they're
taught to explain but I enjoyed it and I
like to Kyle Kinane as saying someone
quite subdued
[Music]
[Applause]
oh look at all this snow come out of the
screening and it is a winter wonderland
melenz keeps fogging up in this weather
I just saw margery Prime which as you
saw from that little intro there great
cast of Geena Davis and Tim Robbins and
Jon Hamm and Louis Smith and I I really
enjoyed it
you wouldn't say I loved it but I liked
it a lot you can definitely tell it's
based on a plague it's very dialogue
heavy and talky all about you know set
in a near future where you when someone
dies you have a prime which is like a
hologram and so I just let it wash over
me and it was very slow so it's a bit
challenging but I thought it was good
performances and once I got into the
mood of seeing it like a play then yeah
I liked it you guys think social going
to another party today see you tomorrow
so overall out of the films that I've
seen so far my favorite is Wind River
directed by Taylor Sheridan then mud
found directed by D Rees
Briggs B bear I loved as well a very
funny sweet drama comedy LA times just
appeal to me on a personal level about
love in LA and I don't feel at home in
this world anymore long title and
definitely worth watching that's it for
this week I hope you enjoyed coming
along with me for the journey here at
the Sundance Film Festival I'm Alicia
Malone you can check to me on Twitter at
Alicia Malone let me know in the
comments below what you thought of
buying video diaries and I will see you
soon wait